getting your car washed is normally a
bit of a chore but here in northridge
people are getting more car washes than
necessary and that's because of
something delicious lurking inside they
always say what inside the car wash how
cool what happened how did you get here
it's uh really funny because nobody
would think that we are here
i'm lillian and i'm the owner of
lillian's bread and sweets and we're
located inside a car wash
[Music]
lillian opened her restaurant in the car
wash for one simple reason she knew that
being located in a car wash would
provide foot traffic and some new
clients
when you walk into cruisers you are
confronted by the smells of little tree
air fresheners steering wheel covers and
other car cleaning paraphernalia but you
are also confronted with the smell of
home cooked filipino food
filipino food is simple but delicious
we eat a lot of pork chicken and beef
and rice of course we cannot eat our
food without rice
we are famous for our halo halo our halo
halo they always say is the best
in the west
it is to die for as someone who ate
three hollow hollows in 24 hours i can
attest it's really great
filipino food tends to be overlooked
internationally but it's gearing up to
be the next big thing in the culinary
world
on average in a day
we sell about
300 meals
cooking is really a passion for me
yeah because if you're not passionate
with what you're doing then you won't be
able to succeed
i'm really so grateful and thankful that
i have my team because without them i am
nothing i think that's my secret so the
next time you treat yourself to a car
wash you can splurge on more than just a
pine scented air freshener you can
splurge on that empanada scented plate
of filipino food guaranteed to make your
car smell better than a little air
freshener ever could
[Music]
you